hey youtubers is charlie so Comic Con
continues this is going to be my marvel
comic con preview along with like my
schedule for the rest of the week so
I'll talk about the Marvel stuff first
then I'll talk about when all the other
videos are coming you know based on when
panels are happening when trailers are
dropping so here we go so Marvel's kind
of spread its stuff out between TV and
movie stuff like the big movie panel is
going to be Saturday night but it's Luke
Cage panel is going to be happening on
thursday they'll probably talk about
other netflix defender stuff so like
jessica jones season 2 now the only
thing that they've confirmed is jessica
jones season 2 is in production so
that'll pry premiere sometime next year
after defenders so while they're
currently finishing iron fist I'm not
expecting a big presentation or anything
like that most of their Luke Cage panel
will be spent hyping up Luke Cage is
going to be awesome but just to remind
you guys about the stuff next year iron
fist will drop probably sometime in the
spring when daredevil season to drop
this year then they'll have defenders
during the summer then Jessica Jones
then they'll start everything again
it'll be like daredevil season 3 so on
so forth but you get the idea Luke Cage
coming real soon then iron fist then
defenders so they'll probably say a few
things about the other series during
that Luke Cage panel but the only
trailer I'm expecting is going to be for
Luke Cage so they probably will drop a
trailer so when they do that's probably
what i'll do my video for and then i'll
just talk about the stuff that they
talked about during the panel inside
that trailer video that kind of goes for
all the other videos that i'm doing this
week punisher i almost forgot about
punisher of course they're making a
punisher solo TV series for netflix you
know it'll be with Jon Bernthal
character but they haven't confirmed
when that's going to drop when they're
going to start filming it so it's just
like floating around in there somewhere
so I'm not expecting a whole lot from
that so moving forward Friday and
Saturday Friday for Marvel is actually
pretty low-key even though there's a
bunch of TV stuff happening they're
doing their agents of shield season four
panel they'll probably drop some footage
if you didn't catch the season finale
like the big t up for season four was
life model decoys the Inhumans are still
a thing like they're still floating
around but life model decoys are really
like the big new thing that they're
doing Saturday Marvel movies so what's
happening at the marvel panel is they
typically don't announce all the things
that they're bringing they just say
marvel panel special presentation from
Kevin foggy so what they end up doing
is is like at the last minute they'll
try to get actors for movies that are in
production so like the only thing that
they've confirmed that they're hyping up
is guardians of the galaxy to like James
Gunn is going to be there with the cast
they're gonna drop some footage it won't
be public but I'll still do a video
about it it just won't have any of the
special effects that you'll see in the
final version of the movie but dr.
strange will also be there so they'll be
hyping the out of that I don't know
if Benedict Cumberbatch is going to be
there because he's not going to be there
for the Sherlock panel later that
weekend but I am expecting a bigger
Doctor Strange trailer so the surprises
like they always sneak in a whole bunch
of Avengers related surprises tomorrow
wall panels even if they're hyping other
movies so black panther chadwick boseman
is actually doing a Marvel signing
earlier in the week so what a
coincidence that he happens to be a
comic-con the week that they're hyping
up all their movies so I would expect
them to show off some concept art and
some ideas for the Black Panther movie
they kind of did that for the Doctor
Strange movie earlier this year but yet
like the other two big surprises I know
you guys are wondering about this
spider-man homecoming and thor ragnarok
so they just started shooting Thor so
I'm not expecting any of the actors to
be there but Tom Hiddleston is actually
doing a Warner Brothers panel for a
different movie he's doing like a king
kong movie with Warner Brothers so
because he's supposed to be a comic-con
they might bring him on to stage for
that marvel panel to talk about Thor
things bring a little crazy low key
energy I don't think he's going to be in
costume like he was in 2013 there has
not been another Hall H panel that's had
an introduction that's strong the big
red man of the hour spider-man
homecoming so they've been shooting the
movie for a long time they definitely
have footage that they could show off
I'm not expecting them to but they will
probably do some sort of teaser whether
it's concept art whether it's actual
footage just to be determined so
whatever ends up happening for that
stuff I will totally do videos there is
a marvel giveaway that I'm doing this
week so all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so that's pretty much
what's going on for marvel at comic-con
so like they have their movies they have
a couple TV shows like the netflix stuff
then they have like the network stuff on
ABC like agents of shield then just a
circle back around to give you guys an
idea for the rest the video so DC is
kind of doing the same deal well they
have their movies that they're hyping up
that's all going to happen on saturday
but the big change from last year is is
that DC is doing like all of its big TV
show panels also on Saturday
and they are all bringing trailers so
here's the schedule so Friday night
walking dead and Game of Thrones are
having their panels there will be a
walking dead nicon trailer not expecting
any footage for Game of Thrones but then
Saturday here's going to be the order
for DC panels so it's going to start in
the morning with their movies the movie
panel is actually in the morning it's
going to be fun they're hyping up Wonder
Woman in Suicide Squad I'm not expecting
any justice league stuff because they're
in the middle of filming that they might
tease that a little bit but they're
mostly there for Wonder Woman in Suicide
Squad so I'm expecting like the first
big Wonder Woman trailer to post and
then maybe some kind of suicide so
they've already been dropping a whole
bunch of Suicide Squad trailers so I
don't know what more they would post
that they are already posting this week
so Wonder Woman Suicide Squad maybe some
small justice league stuff TV stuff all
dropping after that Super Girl Season
2's first then legends of tomorrow
season 2 then the flash season 3 then
arrow season 5 each of them is dropping
a new trailer so of course I'm going to
be doing trailer videos for all that
stuff so what's probably gonna happen is
because that's like way too many videos
for me to make in a single day I'm just
gonna prioritize so like some of them
will post on Saturday night some of them
will post on Sunday it is gonna be crazy
this weekend so I'll just I'll give
people schedule updates for related
things so like if I'm doing a DC video
and there's like a bunch of other DC
trailers for me to get through I'll just
let you guys know whenever I post those
videos so I'll be live tweeting a lot of
this too so you can follow me on Twitter
and Facebook if you want updates on when
videos are coming or just like crazy
that's happening minutes a minute
and they did say like the one thumbs
down is that there's no free Wi-Fi on
the convention floor this year so
because pokemons go is down there you
will probably find 0 cellular service
but hopefully this gives you a little
better idea for the videos that I'm
going to be working on this weekend
while you guys wait for me to post all
that you can click here for like my
master comic-con play this issue says
like everything that I'm doing this week
for comic-con and you can click here for
my spider-man homecoming behind the
scenes
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight